it came to my attention soon and it
shocked me because you and I go way way
way way back yeah for either one of us
run television yeah you always seemed
like the last person that I knew in the
world that would ever get a medical
marijuana card and I'm told you have one
yes I love it I love indica which is the
one that sort of turns the switch off I
don't need a switch turned on I need to
slow things down
right cuz you know what every day it's
the same cycle for me I get up I go in
the bathroom I look in the mirror and I
swear I do this I go hey how are you
it shows the day is full of potential
yeah around three o'clock I have a cup
of coffee try and keep it going
but know I'm full of regret and
disappointed I get home before I go to
bed I take a nap before you go to bed
you take a nap because I have no trouble
napping okay I have trouble sleeping at
night but I'm a great mapper huh I get
up from my nap I think about all the
regret and disappointment
I spoke some indica I go to sleep start
it all over so you say you have regrets
and disappointments and the indica
marijuana makes that all go away if they
blow it away because all the now you're
shouting I think you've heard me do that
no because the regrets and disappoints
are small they're not big I don't have
big regrets in my life right but every
night I have small regrets and small
doesn't why did I say that why'd I do
that right I mean I smoked it gone and
then gone forever I think you would be
good smoking some pop
you know I'm not tell you something
right now I don't great yeah that's I
don't know this is your electric card
okay okay there's all my information now
there you get realize there's more so
much information driver's license has
nothing on your pot a card has your
astrological sign well the thing is it's
legal in California but if you have a
pot card it's actually cheaper and they
put you in the front of the line okay
I'm gonna tell you something I've had
many people over the years pretty much
everyone I know say dude you need to
smoke marijuana no use the indica and
indica specific all right that you don't
you be smoking sativa my friend that
will send you down the wrong path people
like you you're like a Somali a of pot
you're now called to my table beforehand
and I sniffed the board also I only
started smoking pot at 50 yeah you know
it got me hooked
whoopee goo and we were talking and I
was telling her about my steps you saw
her under a bridge and she got you
hooked you're talking old-timey talk
yeah okay you're right the world of
marijuana that's not the world of
marijuana so she gave me a pen like a
vape pen wait what is he doing this on
the air no in her dressing room give me
a very pen she gave me numbers to call
of the good places here that you can get
it with your medical card or free yeah
but you know we don't need one so this
is so Whoopi Goldberg got you started on
this on this sad road into drug addition
I have sampled it on several times and
there's no change nothing happens to me
nothing happens to me and I'm not really
another sampling with and I don't know
what you're tied in it under a doctor's
supervision while he was there there's
no no I made that up that's [ __ ]
what does that mean what does that mean
hey Doc I want to try some pot I'll do
it with you right here but I have to
watch you thanks doc you're real aces
what kind of crazy scenario is that I
got a new puppy yeah is it gonna sit
with my puppy it's delightful yeah what
does one have to do with the other ah I
just said I'm gonna smell some later I
got a new puppy but if you guys have
some pot to calm you down around a puppy
no but both of them together delightful
yeah so like you and the puppy just puff
it up yeah I've been told by my sons
one's gonna be 18 tomorrow
the other ones 22 I've always told them
don't you get drunk around me if you're
drunk around me or get in trouble I need
your smoking pot you're the older one
get a medical card you know and I'm like
hey man because nothing what drinking
there's fighting there's murder there's
car accidents pot nothing man
you just don't get things done
you know it's like later on you're like
I didn't get a chance to murder that guy
I never got her out to it I'm still on
the couch and I had murder in today
you